foreign
[Music]
hey welcome to generative AI for
Defenders with SEC palm-2 and duet AI
that is a mouthful
um but thanks for coming and uh I let's
go ahead and get the clicker and get
situated and I'm erikter I lead the
security operations engineering at
Google cloud and all of the platform
work we're doing around security Ai and
I have a little later in the session
with me Jada Paul who's the CSO have
done in Bradstreet who's going to talk a
little bit about their Journey as well
as Rex dexton who uh leads everything
interesting at Accenture related to
security and is going to come on stage
and talk a little bit about their
experience but I want to kind of Jump
Right In and oh I should also say my
apologies for the profile picture I
wanted to have a serious security
picture because I'm a serious security
individual and then someone told me that
it makes me look like I'm a Hitman and
so uh but it was we couldn't change the
slides blah blah blah so you know here
we are uh but we're really here to talk
about about Ai and I don't know if
you've noticed but at Google next we're
a little bit excited about generative AI
uh but but I do want to kind of take a
step back and say look as excited as we
are about the possibilities that
generative AI is unlocking across all
the fields of Technology
um it's still a tool and the tool has to
solve real problems it's not interesting
to think about tools just for Tool's
sake or Tech just for text sake and and
we've framed kind of talking to many
customers many of you we think there are
three big problems in Security today and
uh we had to be alliterative so threats
Toil and talent are the three and
obviously uh many of you deal with these
every day you read them out them in the
news every day the increasing hostility
of the threat landscape the growth of
the attack surface uh you know the
reality is we hire Amazing Security
Experts and have them work on our team
and many of them tell us that they love
the mission of security of protecting
their organization protecting the planet
and kind of hate their job because
there's a lot of toil there's a lot of
things that just kind of suck and
shouldn't take a human but do take a
human today and then the third of course
is the well-publicized talent Gap
depending on who you believe hundreds of
thousands maybe even millions of open
jobs that we just can't fill with
trained people in cyber security and
we're quite excited about how generative
AI can help in each of these domains and
I'd say we already know that there's
many places this can happen and we're
still expanding the possibilities of
where generative AI can do more to help
us solve these real problems in
preventing threats the most interesting
mission
is to say if you borrow from the medical
world
we may not be able to prevent patient
zero in all cases but how can we prevent
patient one patient two patient three
how can we make it so a bad actor can
use a new and novel technique once at
most not hundreds or thousands of times
which is the common practice today uh
toil how can we move to a world where
humans are using their brains to do what
only humans can do and a lot of the
drudgery the monotony the you know alert
triage review all that copy and paste
between different tools how can we take
a huge chunk of that out of the daily
life so security personnel and how can
we both
make it so that each individual on your
security team does more is capable of
having more impact but also how do we
help those people who are new in career
to up level their skill set again these
are places where we see generative AI
being very helpful
we've announced uh a few first party in
our in our current security tools we've
announced duet Ai and a few scenarios if
any of you caught the main keynote
yesterday or the security Spotlight
keynote today we did a bunch of Demos in
those I'd encourage people to watch them
if they weren't able to see them I think
it's pretty exciting some of the
capabilities we're bringing to bear and
just very briefly I'll hit on three of
them you know mandian threat
intelligence is of course one of the
most trusted resources to learn about
everything we know as mandian and
everything we know now with Mandy and
Google fused together about the threat
landscape from doing over a thousand
incident response investigations every
year the worst of the worst breaches in
the world and taking the techniques and
tactics that we find there synthesizing
them attaching them to the actors who
are abusing good people on the planet
and then making it so that you can take
advantage of that and protect yourself
the beautiful thing about it is how much
information we have and the worst thing
about it is how much information we have
because if you go start researching
threat actors that attack oil and gas
good luck it takes a long time this is a
classic example of where generative AI
can help you find what you're looking
for summarize it help you prepare the
reports or the tools you might be
preparing to protect your organization
Chronicle security operations are Sim
takes in
tremendous amounts of data helps you
synthesize it and make it actionable
it's amazing sub-second search across
petite acts of information and there's a
learning curve
yesterday you had to learn the syntax of
udm and Yara l in order to be truly
proficient in the tool and now we've
added natural language conversion to so
that you can get going faster be more
productive and kind of learn as you go
another as well as places like you have
a complex case you understand what's
going on
but do you have to be an expert or do we
help summarize for you what we're seeing
and allow you to dig in when you dig in
these are the kinds of things that
generative AIS is doing and and last but
not least in security Command Center
which is our tool that helps protect
your workloads on gcp we're doing a lot
to help you understand not just
theoretical vulnerabilities but the
actual exploitable attack paths looking
at your configuration what's actually
exploitable and helping you prioritize
but again
to really get the most out of that
yesterday you needed to be pretty deep
in security generative AI can help
translate some of that up level it have
you focus on where you need to focus and
even help you with the recommendations
and the actions you should take to fix
it these are three examples of what
we're doing in our current products but
what we're really here to talk about
today is what's powering this and how
are we taking a platform approach
to generative AI
and this is a fancy diagram that has a
lot of conf of information on it but I
want to tell the story of what led to
this very briefly you know parts of
Google have been working on AI for over
a decade and you know everyone I think
knows at this point that you know
Google's been involved in generative AI
from the very beginning doing some of
the foundational research
I and some parts of my team have been
doing AI for a while but we have not
been doing generative AI for five years
and when we started last year saying
we're going to dig in we see the
potential of generative AI we did not
day one say we're going to build a
platform and open that up to the world
to come and build security use cases
with partners and customers what we did
is we said this seems really useful
let's figure out how to use it in our
products and we started we got the
benefit of building on top of the
foundational knowledge uh that that
other parts of Google have been working
on and so that's awesome we got a head
start of doing that but it turns out
those foundational models while they're
trained on Amazing data and on Amazing
scenarios we're not very good at
security
and they're not good at security because
security has a lot of jargon that's not
generally available the jargon is
constantly changing it's got a lot of
proprietary data that's just not
available in the training sets and so
what we quickly learned is we needed to
actually make a security llm
and so we started bringing data sources
that we had because as Google we have a
lot of data at our fingertips and Mandy
and now part of Google Cloud also
brought a tremendous amount of
information about security about threat
actors and things like this we started
training this and out of this came what
we call SEC Palm which is the new
security LOM that is trained to speak
the language of security very very well
and around that we've wrapped the
security AI workbench and security and
this is important because it turns out
just giving you a model isn't enough
it's giving you the tools to actually be
productive with that model in a variety
of applications and use cases
we're using that ourselves in the
products I talked about for a minute
we're working with a variety of Partners
and customers to help bring that to them
and this is all important and it's even
more important that it's built on top of
vertex AI which is of course Google
Cloud's AI platform and we get we get a
lot of things as being part of that
built on top of vertex Ai and one of one
of the best selfishly from my
perspective as a security guy is I don't
have to start and think about how I
build all the Enterprise price grade
controls that that every customer I've
talked to and every partner I've talked
to that that has this top of mind
question how do I secure it how do I
make sure there's not data leakage what
if it's really proprietary data I don't
want other people to have access to
these are problems that vertex has been
working on and solving and building
controls for for years and we're
extending those controls now to
generative Ai and so this is the story
that got us to the aha moment that said
as we started building this we realized
it's hard it requires a lot of unique
data and it requires constant Evolution
because security changes and therefore
the model has to change because the
model has to speak the current language
of security at any point in time it's
not enough that it speaks what security
looked like a year ago or two years ago
and so as we did that we said we need
this for ourselves other people need it
too we need to open this up and we think
it's important
that it's important to any it's building
up a real platform ecosystem and a
partner ecosystem is hard it takes time
and energy and lots of you know good
collaboration and trust and many other
things but one of the things we think is
important is that is that we're both
using it ourselves and working with
partners and I think we get the best
ecosystems when you have that kind of
dynamic where you have the direct
feedback from using it yourself the
direct feedback from a set of trusted
Partners head on
very quickly we build security i o
workbench on top of vertex AI for people
building AI whether they're Partners
extending their Security Solutions and
bringing them to you all as customers or
whether you're a customer who's
stitching together a workflow or
extending something proprietary in your
environment
I won't read everything on this slide I
will emphasize one thing your data your
terms from the beginning we knew this
was important we already spent years
building these controls into Google
cloud and vertex and we're now extending
those into into the work we're doing in
generative Ai and security AI workbench
I've mentioned this a couple of times
but again to emphasize all this is built
on vertex AI it is we recognize there
are a set of security specific use cases
but there are also many use cases that
are some security
some other things and we're actually
seeing some of the most interesting
scenarios coming from the blending of
I'd say business productivity driven use
cases and core security driven use cases
and how all that comes together and one
of the great things about vertex is it
gives you access to everything Google
knows about Ai and you can stitch that
together in whatever way you want
at a high level
um as we've been working with partners
and customers and kind of exploring this
ourselves there are three big categories
of use cases that we're seeing emerge
right now that we think are very well
suited to degenerative Ai and very
interesting again I won't read the slide
but but summarization classification and
and generation and applying that to the
use cases of security
um and we've made a lot of progress in
you know the relatively short time that
we've been working on this and working
with partners
uh it's important to note that as you
think about working with generative Ai
and specifically with SEC palm and AI
workbench uh kind of two high-level
choices a lot of people that we're
working with are saying you know what a
little bit of prompt engineering the the
work you've done to train the model is
great with a little bit of prompt
engineering we can have something really
useful for our use case in other
scenarios people are saying look I need
to extend this I need to write what used
to be called a plug-in but I was told
yesterday I can't say plug-in anymore
and I now have to say extension so an
extension that uh that accesses
real-time data or proprietary data that
you have and brings it into the model at
inference time so that it can form
interesting and correct conclusions
of course
security AI workbench as I said fits
into vertex AI into generative AI Studio
we give you the tools at your fingertips
to do all the experimentation that you
need to do all the fine tuning you need
to do the prompt engineer you need to do
and you know this is a quickly moving
field you should expect that those tools
were getting better and better you know
on a regular basis
just say a quick thing we announced that
we were doing security AI workbench in
SEC Palm 2 at RSA this year so only what
four months ago uh and at the time we
announced that Accenture was joining us
on this journey as the first partner to
help us both build that foundational
model as well as start to extend and
explore some of these use cases and it
and and I thought it would be
interesting to share very quickly what
have we learned in four months I mean it
seemed like a lot of time but I'll tell
you it's been a lot of work in 4.4
months
and I think there's a couple of things
one is you know
for all that the foundational llms are
are really amazing and getting better
all the time for all the the work we've
done to extend and build the security
llm uh prompt engineering is still
important and it's a it's a skill and
it's a skill that a lot of parts of the
industry I think are realizing they need
to build it's not like there's just
enough people who know how to do prompt
engineering so this is about us as an
industry building the capability to go
do this and a lot of the customers and
partners we interacted with at the
beginning are kind of
didn't recognize that was important and
in a lot of cases it's been hey let's
help get your bootstrapped and start
working on that journey of kind of
building that capability
uh it's been a lot of talk about
hallucinations around generative Ai and
techniques to avoid hallucinations like
grounding uh and I think but but there's
an interesting thing which is which is
one of the things that we
love about generative AI is I'll say
that what feels like creativity of
course it's not actual creativity but
what feels like creativity of these
um is part of what makes them productive
and useful and and we're finding that
there's a fine line between
you know locking down a model so much
that it can never hallucinate
and do you destroy what you're trying to
get from a productivity and so there's a
balance to be found there and we're
we're building techniques and evolving
techniques for grounding in certain
categories of data
um so that you know it can be useful in
all the dimensions because of course
nobody wants misleading advice
we've also
heard many use cases many ideas of
places we could do more in security and
compliance and privacy policy things
like that
generally there's a convergence around a
few of these scenarios that are on the
slide lots of people see the need for
that in the daily operations of their
teams
we are hearing more and more about
wanting to do more with code wanting to
do more with policy wanting to do more
with compliance and I think as an
industry we'll get there but crawl walk
run
uh and then finally the just the
diversity of Readiness of organizations
and I say this was with absolutely no
judgment and lots of humility as a
person who if you'd ask me you know 18
months ago I probably couldn't have
spelled Transformer and now I spend a
significant percentage of every day
thinking about Ai and working on AI with
a bunch of people in the team and so it
it I think it's clear that different
people are in different places and kind
of the best advice I can give to
everybody is regardless of where you are
on the journey
you know make sure you're taking
conscious steps to learn and evolve your
own business and looking for places that
it's useful to you
I want to highlight at RSA four months
ago we we said Accenture was joining us
on the journey
a few months later we announced a set of
other partners who are joining us on the
journey and big shout out if there's
another Accenture in the room because
Rex is going to come up in a minute but
uh
um you know
we are better thanks to the partnership
here and we have other partners coming
on board and we'll announce that more
and more over time but the the breadth
of these partners and them pushing our
thinking on scenarios and giving us
feedback on what's working what's not
working
um super valuable in the journey because
it is we're all learning how generative
AI can make security
better than it has been
uh as a quote from the head of Accenture
security which
which I think is pretty awesome and
that's a good segue to invite my friend
Rex up to stage and as I mentioned we've
been hard at work with them for a while
now and it was kind enough to to agree
to both come on stage but also to share
some of the work that they've been doing
so I think we're gonna roll a video and
then chat about it for a minute if if
video works
let's hope so
there we go
in cyber security the threat landscape
is rapidly evolving security operations
centers are challenged to hire retain
and scale the right people deploy adopt
and sustain the right Technologies and
accelerate responses to the
unpredictable threat landscape time to
response is a critical factor in
preventing a catastrophic security
breach
a new threat actors activity has been
attributed to the temp dot Armageddon
campaign where they leveraged a Cobalt
strike Beacon to deliver a malicious
payload to multiple corporations Pat a
security intelligence analyst for
accenture's managed extended detection
and response team noticed the new threat
that could directly impact company
assets Pat quickly logged into the mxdr
platform powered by the Google Cloud AI
security workbench and reviewed the
current detection logic he noticed there
wasn't a rule that would monitor or
alert for this new Behavior
Pat created a new rule and then enabled
the Retro hunt of the rule to determine
if this threat actor was already inside
a client's environment after the Retro
hunt completes the security AI assistant
will send out a Cobalt strike alert
Sam is a security operations center
analyst on the same team as Pat
Sam worked with his soccer team to
initially develop and deploy the current
threat detection rules at the time Sam
and his Tier 1 peers were new to Sock
operations and may not have strong
enough rules in place to detect respond
and mitigate threaten activities
spawning from the use of cobalt strike
beacons Sam is utilizing a security AI
assistant chat meanwhile Morgan who does
not work for Accenture is faced with the
same situation as Sam without an AI
assistant
hello
Hi Sam I hope you had a good weekend I
received two important alerts that I
need to share with you
identified one miter attack tactic
techniques and procedure at play I've
also attached the alerts for your
reference
please let me know if you have any
questions
Sam asks the AI assistant about Cobalt
strike attacks and how they are used he
receives a summarized explanation of
cobalt strike attacks and a list of its
related attackers and uses
how should I escalate this alert I
suggest
escalate the incident to Fred Vespucci a
level 3 sock specialist the triggered
alerts might indicate a dangerous
exploit with Cobalt strike attempting to
compromise Two Hosts
considering the severity of these alerts
it is highly probable that the
activities stem from a Cobalt strike
Beacon a large language model SEC Palm
considers the level of criticality or
severity miter attack framework tactics
similar historic incidents and chooses
an appropriate path of escalation the
suggested action is to escalate this
incident to Fred Vespucci a level 3 sock
specialist to avoid further breaches
while Sam has rapidly escalated the
incident Morgan would take much longer
to research and decide how to best
escalate the situation
thanks can you generate a client
incident report for me
security AI assistant generates a client
incident report
the incident was escalated for further
investigation and initial remediation
steps were taken a copy of the client
incident report document has been saved
the security AI assistant generates the
client incident report as a Word
document so he can review edit and share
with his client meanwhile Morgan has
spent the larger portion of the day
manually creating an incident report
okay this is done can you give me
feedback the AI assistant will look at
its chat history and incident metadata
Sam receives real-time feedback while
Morgan will not get feedback until a
meeting later in the week
utilizing the security AI assistant Sam
was able to accurately escalate the
incident create an incident report and
receive critical feedback in minutes for
security analysts without the security
AI assistant this would take hours
it's just one analyst story at scale an
organization would benefit from 80 to 90
Time Savings allowing analysts to focus
on important and critical tasks
yeah well it's so cool to see obviously
I've seen it before but uh so cool to
see the progress that Accenture has made
and I'd love to just hear a little bit
about the journey right yeah no it was
super exciting so when we met at RSA and
I know Connie and Jonathan are here and
they put a lot of work into this and
Scott as well you know we went out to
you know it's all new to us right we
went out we identified 70 plus use cases
that we wanted to do and then we met
with your team and found out that you
were doing 30 of them
and so we didn't want to be redundant
and so we focused on on what made sense
to work on and and they think you know
the the two areas that we found you know
in your thing were Toil and scale right
those are the two areas that we focused
on because we feel there's not enough
Security Professionals in the world
um to do this and so if we can automate
a lot of these tasks and get people
doing the right kind of work we can help
you know scale this this business from
that perspective I think the
collaboration we talked about prompt
engineering and all that I mean we sent
over a boatload of prompts and it didn't
work
and then we had to refine and learn and
and I think that journey and that
process and the collaboration between
the two teams I mean this actually works
that's in our mxdr portal right now and
the thing is that we if we showed it to
you it would be like a two-minute demo
and you'd be like oh so we had to put a
story around it that's why that's all
the drama and the voices but do but I
think but I think the collaboration with
your team has been you know Bar None
amazing and I think you know and and
this is just one of the use cases the
other one around around Cloud security
and and the auto remediation and code
generation is super amazing too but yeah
so that's kind of it from that
perspective any uh any advice to folks
who are maybe a little earlier on the
journey on you know things to focus on
things to think about wow yeah I think
the thing the mistake that we made is we
thought we wanted to do our own llm
initially right and then what we quickly
realized is that it's about the data and
the Telemetry and who has that trusted
security data and the reason we're
excited I'm working with SEC promise
because I think we talked about you have
80 of the internet you have all the
mandated threat until you have you know
the virus total deep mind all that all
that data and and being able to train
and have access to that and and and to
you know to be able to provide the
prompts and then leverage our own
extensions to create our own unique IPS
it's super important so it's about more
about understanding what's out there and
what can be trusted because I think you
talked about insights versus
hallucinations I thought that was quite
a fascinating thing you know it you are
going to have you know some
hallucinations I think on the cloud
piece we struggled with that a bit but
we we were able to train and tune and
drive that to where we had enough
efficacy to feel that we would get more
value out of it than worried about you
know the two percent of hallucinations
that we would give right from from that
perspective so well that's awesome
well uh any kind of parting thoughts for
folks who are on the journey or any or
any you know beat me up about anything
on stage no I think no I think you know
the one thing I can say is you know
we've been working with your team for a
year now once we decided to re-platform
and and and the collaboration that we've
been able to do with you guys as far now
it's you you guys are huge but you act
small I think that the collaboration the
ability to work together and drive these
meaningful pieces is super important I
think the other thing is you know
understand from your partners what
they're already developing because you
don't want to build redundant
capabilities right I think that was step
one for us and and then you know what
we've done is is they stopped here and
we took it from there and then you're
getting double the work double the value
out of it versus trying to build
something that's already going to be out
there from that perspective that's
awesome all right well thank you for the
partnership and thank you I look forward
to keeping working on this together
[Applause]
oh I used the wrong slide
uh so next I want to bring up Jada Paul
who's the CSO at dun and Bradstreet a
good customer great customer on gcp
working with us on security and AI
yeah are you on oh can you guys hear me
yeah there we go
um so I'd love let me just introduce
yourself talk a little bit about the
dungeon Bradstreet journey and kind of
what you've been doing uh with us over
the last couple of years sure first
thanks for having me and we'll talk a
little bit about Donna brashery and what
we are in
who we are and what we do uh most
notably you know for those of you who
are familiar with the duns number which
is kind of something similar to a social
security number uh as an individual or
as a person it is a social security
number for your for your business and we
are a global leader in decisioning data
and analytics so we have more data than
you can possibly imagine and and when we
talk about what we're going to talk
about around gen Ai and models the data
the cleanliness the the
um the quality is most important because
what comes in is you know what you get
out so
um as a CSO I'm I'm a strong believer in
enabling you know the the role of the
CSO has changed drastically over the
last you know let's say two to three
years uh where we we need to really
focus on being more of an enabler versus
you know that historical department of
of no and I think this this opportunity
with what we're doing now with enabling
the organization to to leverage gen Ai
and these llms
um is really a unique opportunity for us
because
um you know hit you know it's always
been challenging for a CSO to find that
where do I drive value where do I offer
value outside of just protecting the org
and truly this is one of those those
opportunities for us
well that's awesome can you talk a
little bit I know you launched recently
the the AI labs and you've been on the
journey with vertex and gcp can you just
talk a little bit about how that's gone
for sure I mean most recently I mean we
we actually had an announcement that hit
the wires yesterday with regards to
Jenny iLab so we we released gen AI Labs
as an opportunity for us to co-innovate
with our customers right bring an
opportunity for them to come in and
basically play with us and learn with us
and build some some
um you know innovative solutions and
opportunities and yesterday we announced
uh explicitly that vertex AI is a major
part of that initiative and we are
largely building our labs around vertex
AI capabilities
that's awesome thanks for the the
congratulations on the announcement
thanks for the partnership what um
what are the things I know that is
getting top of mind for people
especially as they're starting to
use more AI techniques gender to AI is
is how do we think about the security of
those systems as well and I know this is
something you've thought a lot about you
know any thoughts on how you're
approaching it and what we can do as an
industry yeah I mean first I'll talk a
little bit about the Journey of how we
got to where we're at with regards to
gcp itself we've been on this journey
for about 18 months of building you know
gcp platform out secure by default right
you guys Google calls it invisible
security Etc but uh you know the idea of
being able to build a the platform from
the ground up as code
um being it repeatable consumable for
our devops teams for our data scientists
when we talk a little bit about you know
securing models themselves I didn't want
the teams to have to worry about
securing the underlying infrastructure I
wanted that that's already the case
right so we're there and we built you
know again everything infrastructure as
code and we took a three-phased approach
first being leveraging Google's gcp's
default capabilities yesterday there
were some really really good sessions if
you missed them on you know kind of
building gcp by default like you know
the concept of the blueprints the the
security blueprints which is really uh
the way to you know
introduce that secure by default and
then phase two of that really is
building consumable repeatable modules
so that they're secure by default
they're easily consumable and the teams
that are building on top of them don't
have to worry about uh configuring them
you know or building them from scratch
it's already a you know a predefined
model and then three is obviously the
compliances code making sure that nobody
can do anything that we otherwise
wouldn't want them to do so when you
take care of that piece
focusing on protecting the models
themselves is where we're is what we're
looking for so that really comes down to
you know
protecting data I mean a traditional
cyber program if done well you already
have data security you already have
identity management you know those are
all still application product security
it all still core components to be able
to protect the model there are some
novel threats that are introduced as a
result of
you know llms and whatnot and those are
the one-offs that you're going to have
to manage like poisoning and you know
prompt injection and all those things
but I think you take care of
the basics you take care of you know 80
of the risk yeah very good
um and as a as a Defender you know
you and your team were on the trenches
of you know protecting the organization
and and as you think about the use cases
and you saw some of the stuff from from
Accenture some of the stuff we're
working on you know what jumps out at
you as being you know something you
think boy my team could take advantage
of that or Boy I can't wait until
something capability comes first of all
that was that was a great demo that was
really cool I do think I think a couple
of things lowering the barrier to entry
they we think of what llms and
things like chat GPT or bringing it
slower the barrier to entry for threat
actors right you know easier phishing
emails Etc
um same goes for cyber Security
Professionals right like
this is giving the opportunity for
people to maybe do things that they
wouldn't normally do or that they would
normally have to take some time to learn
right like writing queries in in
chronicle having that natural language
processing takes away the need to learn
how to write those things or analyzing
large and large amounts of data I think
you've touched on it when you opened up
like
we are dealing more with more and more
data today than we ever have before but
it's not possible for a human to
to to be able to analyze all that data
you know is as as quickly or as
efficiently or even you know uh
realistically as we would like so this
is giving llms and machine llms will
give an opportunity for us to be able to
uh process much more data much faster I
think threat intelligence right largely
for most threat intelligence programs
they are threat feeds you get a bunch of
IP addresses some hashes Etc uh and
really there's no context to it I do
think that gen AI is going to bring us
along with what you guys are doing with
mandya bring us a a more contextually
aware
um threat intelligence capability to
actually really pull the the needle out
of the stack of needles so to speak and
then I think I think at some point I
think we're not there yet application
development secure coding will be an
area where we see gen AI offer some
really really strong capabilities it's
safe it's going to take some time to get
there because of where the data is
coming from and what it's learning on
but I do eventually believe that that
will be a a way to improve the developer
experience and get code to Market much
quicker than it securely much quicker
than that's happening today that's great
and and any advice for folks maybe
earlier in the journey on things to
think about things just you know avoid
start
yeah I would say a couple things Focus
again focus on the basics
don't get too wrapped up on how advanced
you know generative AI is and you're
only looking at the threats associated
with it you do have to deal with those
but the underlying stuff is really uh
the stuff that's going to protect you
most most of the way governance is super
important don't start jumping right into
doing Tech and building models until you
have a good governance in place with
your with your legal team with your
compliance team because at the end of
the day that all of that is what matters
the most when you're protecting your
intellectual property making sure that
you're not using somebody else's
intellectual property so those things
are are super important
um and and focus on the Frameworks right
you've got
you know you got secure AI Google has
its secure AI framework which is really
set out to help you define a roadmap on
on securely building uh gen AI systems
but you know nist has this risk
management framework you know the miter
Atlas framework allows us to do threat
detection
um and then top 10 has you know as
specific llm focus on on application uh
risks associated with the developing
model so focus on the stuff and really
focus on the basics not don't try to get
too caught up in being Advanced and the
last thing I'll say is when we talk
about models um you know what vertex AI
has brought to us I think is the idea of
this end-to-end capability right we
don't have to worry about too much on
the inside it does sit inside our
account right so our data is our data
it's not going anywhere you're bringing
preset defined models with the model
Garden so we don't have to worry as much
about that through the you know the way
you've built the platform and this
allows us to focus on the data let's
focus on the front end what is getting
developed to interact with the model and
be very careful about the models that
you choose because you know the wrong
model the wrong open source model could
certainly have uh an adverse impact you
know on you as far as protecting
intellectual property because there are
a lot of Open Source license models out
there that are unfavorable yeah to your
work well thank you so much for being a
great customer and a great partner and
coming in and talking with the group
here today thanks for having me
foreign